i i feel like at this point you have to
to take advantage of that insane fact
that the government can come in and shut
down
many different types of commerce right
now so what you want to do is position
yourself
in a in an industry or business that
would give you the greatest likelihood
of being insulated from any of those
shutdowns so
things that are you know delivered
online and
can be done from a home and get
delivered through the mail
those are the sort of things right now
that everyone is focusing on things that
are
you know virtualizing basically
everything
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an entrepreneur a motivational speaker a
best-selling author
and the original wolf of wall street
jordan belfort finally welcome to the
reuben report
how are you i'm glad to be here i am
good well i thought you'd be a perfect
guy to have on this week because we are
both
in this crazy town of los angeles i've
i've been
to your house it ain't bad my friend
you've got you're in your beautiful
studio and you've got a pretty swank
setup
but tomorrow gavin newsom is going to
allow us to leave our homes can you
believe it's actually happening
you know let me give you my take on it i
don't think anybody really listened to
him
i don't think there was any lockdown
that i noticed other than that i feel
terrible for restaurant owners who were
forced
for no good reason at least in my
opinion to
close their outdoor dining after they
spent tons of money putting in the
safeguards that
one would need to have outdoor dining
and all the
barriers petitions tears i mean it's
crazy and then
just i mean i really feel bad but i i
have to say other than
that i think that there was like corona
fatigue here
in la and it was more of a ceremonial
lockdown i remember the first lockdown
davey there was no one on the street
there was no cars around this was not
that over the last four weeks he was
like oh let's screw over all the
restaurant owners and just like wipe
them out of business that's kind of what
it felt like to me how about you
yeah i mean i think well my audience
knows i mean we've basically been
ignoring it around here and i feel bad
for the small
business owners and and the restaurant
tours and you know it's sad when i'm in
your neighborhood or even in my
neighborhood where you drive by the main
drags and you know everything
everything's closed but that's kind of a
that's kind of a good spot
for us to start because for the for the
people that
know you they they know leo the leo
dicaprio version of you
um but in a way you're you're kind of a
startup guy you're like
you're gritty and you get out there and
you do stuff that's what your whole
career the ups and the downs has been
about how if you
right now we're just trying to start up
something
um how would you feel in the midst of
knowing that the government can just
come in
and and shut you down at any point i
feel like at this point
you have to to take advantage of that
insane fact
that the government can come in and shut
down
many different types of commerce right
now so what you want to do is
position yourself in a in an industry or
business
that would give you the greatest
likelihood of being
insulated from any of those shutdowns so
things that
are you know delivered online and can be
done from a home
and get delivered through the mail those
are the sort of things right now
that everyone is focusing on things that
are you know virtualizing basically
everything so i think
you know i hate to say this but it's
true like in the worst of times
you typically have the most opportunity
for people who are willing to go out
there and take
risks so like if i look at my business
and i had this conversation with someone
just last night about you know that
there's a new round of ppp
loans coming out and i i apply for it
and i deserve to get it my business got
decimated decimated my speaking business
because that was my core business but
now i'm doing well because i have a new
business
but the point is is like if you what
business you were in last year you have
to say okay
well in the new reality the new normal
if you want to call it
those rules you know you can't just go
out there and do business the way you
used to do it i have people working in
my house i don't have an office
i focus on online delivery on virtual
learning on
other things i know that won't be as
impacted so i think that you you have to
go out there right now and assume that
at any given moment the wrong can be
pulled out from under your feet and
while when we were growing up we used to
call like oh let's go into defensive
industries like
like food and like everyone needs to eat
right like the movies everyone go
those are like defensive industries
right well now defensive industries are
characterized as things that are
defensive that can't be
shut down by draconian state and
government measures insane
so do you think that's kind of the key
to being a good business person a good
a good business guy in general someone
who can like just see that things have
changed like i think a lot of people
right now they still think that the old
world's coming back they still think
february 2020 is coming back but
february 2021 is going to be way
different
than february 2020 and i don't think
february 2020 comes back
i i think this is one thing that's
that's um that's
always constant in this world and that
is that the world is always changing the
difference right now and i
think you're a hundred percent right i
don't think things are going back to the
way they were
ever i really don't um and
not that people won't have you know i
think people will not always wear masks
and i think that
there won't always be people social
distancing because you know if you look
back right now in the middle of bubbles
with things like bitcoin and all this
crazy stuff going
on with some real estate prices soaring
in certain areas
and you look back in 2008 and we didn't
learn anything it's
it's the same thing again another bubble
yeah so people like you know
it's really bad after 2008 in 2000 i was
like oh
like we got to be really careful we
can't have bubbles and people forget
really quickly
but i think you're right though that
like i think that the
there's a new way that people have
become accustomed to consuming
everything whether it's food movies
learning buying products i think that
people have gotten
comfortable right now or used to and
even prefer in some
respects to buy things and stay home and
i think that's never going to change i
think that's going to be here to stay
there's a movie
some crazy movie that was that was i
think bruce willis was in this movie
where they oh call what was it called
where they're like they all lived
virtual lives
they're like actually locked away in
these like little shells there have like
their counterparts like their their
clones go out there
and move through the world because it's
too dangerous and too deadly with
viruses and diseases
i can't wait it's a really interesting
move but it's almost like we're heading
towards i feel like
yeah i'm shocked i don't know what that
is but it's got it's got a bit of the
matrix in there for sure
right like we're just we're just the
batteries for the digital world in
essence
basically yeah i i think that one you
know one of the things you brought was a
very good point is that
you know what makes a great business
person it's not just seeing it's also
the ability to pivot quickly it's
pivoting and learning how to be wrong
quickly too you have to learn how to try
things and be wrong
and live to fight another day not to get
so emotionally involved in the things
that you're trying where you feel like
i gotta make it work because like you
know i went this far and you know no
this is a bad idea and like you know you
try it doesn't work
next and really to not get caught up in
bad ideas not to go down rabbit holes
and also just to keep trying and trying
and trying and again until
you find that model i think if you do
that right now
there is a path to success for everybody
out there no matter how
desperate things might seem right now so
that right there is what i want to spend
most of our time
talking about because that's that's your
expertise and you've you've it's not
something you're just talking about
you've
you've freaking lived it but but i live
again again
but one thing before we get to that
since since we are both in la
right now my audience knows like you
know i went to florida a couple weeks
ago i was happy man it was open and good
people were smiling like there was some
great energy there and everything else
are you worried about the future of la
not only because of newsome and
lockdowns and all that but
the progressive mayor garcetti here and
just generally the amount of homeless
and drugs and
the whole freaking thing yeah i'm out of
here i'm getting out of here uh
uh oh you are oh great yeah yeah you're
you're on my short list of like four
friends left now
i gotta go you know i might keep i might
keep a
small apartment here at some point i
mean i i i can't you know listen
california was the place that everybody
else
dreamed of moving to it's this and the
weather is beautiful
the terrain is beautiful the air is
mostly clear at least where we are right
and um but you know i think you know
really poor
political policies have turned it into a
freaking cesspool not only that
but to a high tax cesspool and i don't
care paying i'm okay to pay taxes if
they're gonna use those taxes
for for great things but they're not you
know they use the taxes
they're wasted um and i just i can't
it's just
it's honestly beyond the pale what's
happening here and
i think the only solace i could take is
i think it's worse than san francisco
so like i mean i i think it's actually
worse there right so oh well it's not as
bad there yet
right so um i plan on moving to florida
um and was but you know what's bobby's
like it's causing a bubble right now
everyone's running to florida driving up
real estate prices i'm kind of waiting
like
you know i don't know but like again
it's this weird thing here where you and
i
are watching we're almost like sitting
here and watching in real time the
decline
and unraveling of once great city
it's insane to watch yeah and what's
also weird about it and i think this
exact same thing happened in san
francisco was it doesn't happen
overnight it takes a couple years but ev
if you talk to literally everybody
anyone that will talk to you
they all admit it's going in the wrong
direction yet for some reason people in
la they can't make the connection
between
voting for policies and and these
politicians and then the bad stuff that
happens there's like a complete
disconnect there
because i i think what happens is that
you know
um and i want to i don't want to get to
left right here yeah because
but i think that what the democrats have
been very very clever and very adept at
at this hearts and minds campaign
of of using this sort of they've linked
these things with some there's some
moral high ground
that they have with things like climate
and and gay rights and other things that
are completely
unlinked to the economy and yet you know
it becomes an emotional issue
and people when they go to the voting
booth often vote based on emotion and
not based on logic
and they've been really really clever
they've consolidated this party which
comes to represent
things that like i think most people
don't agree with
fiscally but they they have this
overwhelming and i think the republicans
on that made some huge errors
like this the gay rights i mean that
good lord i mean stop already i mean
we just stop like like just accept it no
one is it's so
stupid so if the republicans hopefully
will wake up and see what's going on
right now like you know they need to
and they've come a long way i believe
yeah i don't want to get caught up in
the election and stuff but
i i think that it's time for
for the the republican party to be what
it should be
which is the most inclusive party for
everybody
um that cares about less government more
rights for people
and you know not screwing around with
everybody's life and i understand
somehow that and both cars always get
hijacked by the extremists on either
side
but what happens is the extremists on
the left have this moral
high ground so to speak and they're
using that to win the hearts and minds
of young people and the academics and
the high-tech you know mafia there
whatever you want to call it
and it's causing elections to be swayed
in one way and it's
basically taken this once great city and
it's you know essentially flushed it
literally down the drain if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell